اظهرت مشاهد متداوله على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي رفع الهلال الجديد على مناره
باب الملك عبد العزيز في المسجد الحرام
ضمن تجهيزاتي موسم الحج
[موسيقى]
اثار فيديو تحنيط القرش الغردقه قاتل
الشاب الروسي في مصر تساؤلات عن الاسباب
وهو ما برره خبراء معهد علوم البحار
والمتخصصون بان هذا الاجراء متبع في حاله
اصطياد انواع نادره من الاسماك في حالات
قهريه كما حدث مع قرش التايجر النادر
[موسيقى]
في مشهد يحبس الانفاس مقطع فيديو متداول
يظهروا عاملين في مطعم صيني وهم يطيرون في
الهواء بسبب رياح قويه محاولين التمسك
باعمده مظله كبيره فوقهم حتى لا تطير
لكنها طارت وتار البعض معها وتم نقل
المصابين للمستشفى في الصين
[موسيقى]
طفل يتحدث بعمر الاربعه اشهر ويقرا في
عامه الاول بدا طفل بريطانينا الذي يبلغ
من العمر عامين الحديث عندما كان بسن
الاربعه اشهر وتعلم القراءه بعمر عام ما
يجعله واحدا من اذكى الاطفال في سنه ايضا
بدا المشي بعمر ثمانيه اشهر اي قبل اربعه
اشهر من الاطفال الطبيعيين كما بامكانه
العد من واحد الى مئه بسهوله اما الان
فانه يعلم نفسه اللغه الصينيه من اليوتيوب
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات